[Music]
welcome to rhyming city a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct if you are anything like your
talent
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah yeah that didn't
really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and know
how to use this
geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you did you just
talk whoa did you just understand me oh
my god you can understand me I've been
so lonely they tried to talk to me all
the time all they hear is pika pika you
can hear him right guys adorable you're
adorable they can't understand me kiss
you no one else I don't need a Pokemon
period and what about a world-class
detective because if you want to find
your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
magic this brought us
gathering that magic is called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine
yeah tell us what we want to know pipe
yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving you saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
my name is Wade watts my dad picked that
name because it sounded like a
superhero's alter-ego like Peter Parker
or Bruce Banner but he died when I was a
kid my mom too
and I ended up here sitting here in my
tiny corner of nowhere there's nowhere
left to go nowhere
except the Oasis
[Music]
a whole virtual universe
[Music]
people come to the Oasis for all the
things they can do
[Music]
they stay because of all the things they
can be can you feel this
yeah the only place that feels like I
mean anything
the Oasis was the brainchild of James
Halliday oh if you're watching this I'm
dead
I created a hidden-object an easter egg
the first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars and
total control of the Oasis itself
who is this possible and how the hell is
he winning find him in games
I'm talking about blue life-and-death
stuff the Oasis the world's most
important economic resource it's nothing
less than a war for control of the
future
welcome to the rebellion wait
[Music]
I only came in to escape
but I found something much bigger than
just myself
are you willing to fight
helped us save the oasis
I'm Sonic a little ball of super energy
in an extremely handsome package on my
planet people were always after my
powers so I came to yours it gets a
little lonely I can't with that guy are
you hiding out in my garage if they
steal my powers if you conquer the
universe you have to help me Louie no
it's please it's life or death
good morning my royal chum mr. dr.
Robotnik I'm going to give you five
seconds to tell me where it is
wait don't
Road Trip this can't be happening me oh
my god stop back alright yeah what the
world's largest rubber band ball we
gotta see it no this is not some fun
family road trip Yeah right
it was lame gift shop was cool though
whatever this creature is I'm going to
uncover the source its power
[Music]
I just thought you might like a latte
with steamed Austrian goat milk of
course I would a lot of take I love the
way you make them we gotta lay low let
me show you how it's done so super get
out of here yeah time to go
that was an illegal left by the way why
would you throw your life away for this
silly little alien your time is my
friend
[Applause]
and I'm using it to protect my friends
so you're supposed to be Tom's best
friend that he won't shut up about well
I don't see the appeal it's weird you
like hanging out with animals more than
people yeah well animals get me a rescue
George from here was 2 years old George
never would have survived on his own he
definitely trusts you last night
George of 7 feet with 500 pounds
George you okay buddy you're scared it's
okay
this morning his nine feet pushing a
thousand what's happening to my friend
are you familiar with genetic editing
the changes will be incredibly
unpredictable
is he the only one oh you didn't know
about the 30-foot wolf
[Music]
[Applause]
hell of a day huh science experiments
falling from the sky having George on
that plane it's a big mistake
I think we'll be all right
let's go save the world
it's coming back to me back
you have to evacuate Chicago
George didn't ask for this they're gonna
put him down
that's not happening
there's something in the river I was
just thinking the only thing that's
missing right now is the giant crocodile
hey it's me red you know the guy
everybody hated who kind of saved the
whole island anyway war with Leonard in
the pigs what are you gonna do I'm a
foodie still going on those what and
bomb and Chuck are doing whatever they
do I eat dirt and me well I still have
some anger issues but I'm finding
healthier ways to deal with it Fred I
know we've had our differences
but we've discovered that there's a
third island maybe one good reason why I
should believe you now show you the
proof will team
really but this is a hundred times team
together
guys this is my sister silver I just
don't think you're gonna be compatible
with the team oh wow it is such a
pleasure to meet not you but you I like
her we gotta get to the island is what
my assistant was going to say
[Music]
this is the amazing team I've been
working around the clock
well that's disappointing
[Music]
Oh fellow Eagle God how are you doing a
voice yeah I'm just gonna
[Music]
my name is wreck-it Ralph 30 years I've
been doing this it's hard to love your
job when no one else seems to like you
for doing it you're just the bad guy who
wrecks the building if I'm really honest
with myself sure must be nice being the
good guy Ralph you are bad guy but this
does not mean your bed guy I don't want
to be the bad guy anymore
abandon his game welcome to Game Center
station coming everything changes now
Ralph's gone to hero's duty fear is a
four-letter word ladies we can't change
who we are you can't mess with the
program Ralph's ready for this not
leaving you here alone
[Music]
let's close out with the bad guy
affirmation I am bad hold that box
Melanie
why do I fix everything or touch its
make your mama's proud time
good the cops one game at a time off you
her to say to myself I understand it's
your birthday yeah the party's just
getting started
[Applause]
his name's Kellerman we've traced his
bloodline back 500 years to the
Assassin's Creed how has anyone in the
world knows or cares you no longer exist
[Music]
what is this place
[Music]
this is your second chance
[Music]
for me your past you're about to enter
the Animus what you see hear and feel
are the memories of your ancestor he's
been dead for 500 years wait a minute
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition
[Music]
what I saw it there and family
it was
you're watching you waiting to see who
you are
I believe you are destined for great
things that's fine now
[Music]
I work in the dark without the lights
we are assassins
I'm beginning to like this
still talking to your friends it's
complicated many a dear when we first
got together we were different people
[Music]
bye hey Anthony this is a Martha and
Bethany this is mr. grandfather meet you
morning sort of bargain on you you're
not barred he's barging my little Walker
yeah did you guys see Spencer Vicki went
back in we gotta go get him
huh
what who are you oh my god you're
Spencer's grandfather we have Florida
Thank You Milo Walker did I die and turn
into some kind of a small muscular boy
scout are we dead it sure feels good now
sighs okay you have some issues here the
game is busted who's the game I'm not
yet I don't wonder yet
welcome to too much
this next venture is even more
challenging now remember your job
Jumanji is in your hands I have one
important question who is Jumanji as
that barbers boy little girl we did are
we in hell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what the fellows to suit your strengths
and weaknesses smoldering intensity it's
this stupid face you make you having a
heart attack
breathe breathe this whole left side is
shutting down
[Music]